this episode 82 of congratulations is
brought to you by blue apron blue aprons
mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everyone
blue apron achieves this by supporting a
more sustainable food system setting the
highest standards for ingredients and
building a community of home chef last
thing I ate was this meal that was
chicken and I believe some rice and
vegetables and it was so good it's
always good though
every meal is better than the next
anyway check out this week's menu and
get your first three meals free at blue
apron Dom / Congrats that's blue egg
Britain dot-com / congrats to get your
first three meals free blue apron a
better way to cook this episode is also
brought to you by the cash app you know
the cash out because your longtime
listeners of congratulations it's the
simplest way to instantly send money to
friends it's also the number one app in
finance but it didn't get their own
payments alone these days cash app is
changing how people interact with their
money it's adding features you can only
get from a bank and more than a few you
can like the cash card boosts and
Bitcoin download the cash up for free on
the App Store or Google Play mark mark
it and shout out to mr. green for the
remix that you're about to listen to
right now or that you just listened to
know that you're about to listen to
right now right okay well one fire put
it right now so here we go now it
doesn't say wait it says wait 15 seconds
after so here's the new [ __ ] song from
green hip hop on Instagram
[Music]
see it's just that it says wait 15
seconds for theme song on the [ __ ]
copy and he's like no you're supposed to
wait to say shout out to mr. green
afterwards but one fire because the wait
15 have two seconds after theme song
says it after the [ __ ] thing so how
am I supposed to know but it's all good
man you know one fire that's his charm
but we're live on my app here and so
that's what's up and I see people
ordering the new shirts the new
daliyah's shirt the Grand Slam [ __ ]
shirt we could wear that and for an
Grand Slam people all day long man it
gives you it's like a superpower it's
like were the Avengers man only there's
so many of us yeah so we added another
show in Boston dude Boston babies are
coming out man we had three shows and we
have three shows going and then we added
another one cuz the [ __ ] the demand
was popular so we added a fourth show at
the Wilbur Boston get your tickets now
that'll sell out too for sure and who
knows man who knows how many will add I
think Kevin Hart did like 19 one year so
let's try to do 20 that would be [ __ ]
unbelievable I just got back from Cannes
it well I was in Wichita first Kansas
City and then Lincoln and all those
shows were awesome man like I say I
don't know I never know what to expect
do you know we got an Iceland baby right
here on my apps and greetings from
Iceland and his name is ass grimmer as a
grimmer
cool as grimmer that's his first name
and it had some weird fucked-up thing
over the I I can't let it just be
letters you know in different areas you
got to put things above the [ __ ]
letters and that's that's some real
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
you got to put [ __ ] asterisks and
[ __ ] dashes and two dots sometimes if
you're Swedish [ __ ] is that the U or the
O with the two dots above it bro well
you have dots above it what the [ __ ] you
know also I scratched my knee way too
hard on the way
up here trying to get to the [ __ ]
studio which is you know definitely just
scratched my knee way too hard and now I
scratched it so hard then now when I
scratch it it hurts so I was I was uh I
I was in Wichita which dude that I don't
know how these towns are cuz I'm there
for like 12 hours but the shows were so
awesome man you never know what to
expect
and you get to these places and the
babies come out and dude you guys were
awesome
Wichita show was one for the ages Kansas
City show was one for the ages and
Lincoln show was pretty damn good I'm
not gonna say it was one for the ages
but it was pretty damn good it's always
great to have the best show and then the
best show and then one that's not
necessarily the best show but it was a
great show so but the theater in the
Kansas City I did the Arvest bank
theater or whatever it's so funny that
these theaters will be so goddamn
beautiful and then it's just called this
sponsor of it it'll be like you know
yeah the [ __ ] the Hertz theater and
it's like a beautiful theater that was
built in 1910 and it's historic and then
Hertz comes along and it's like we'll
sponsor it and then it they [ __ ] put
the yellow Hertz sign on the [ __ ]
thing hmm but it's such a great theater
it was so great it was sold out I mean
it looked beautiful
every time I you know what's the worst
is that like I'll do these shows there
and and there'll be so many people there
and it'll be like yeah [ __ ] yeah
let's go and then I get there and the
crowds amazing them theaters beautiful
and I'm like I should have [ __ ]
waited and used this to shoot a special
here and then I shoot my specials and
these [ __ ] things sometimes that
aren't the best and it's like okay it's
like I get up there and I'm like keg
crowd hey crowd be better and also be
also theater be more descript
you know because
want to [ __ ] yeah but dude I don't
know if you've been catching up with my
Instagram stories I've been trying to
post up more and I've been trying to
post more the [ __ ] what do you call
it more of the instagrams
the more you post the more followers
again I noticed but uh I saw I saw do
did you see the one where I put it on my
story and then I just had to put it on
my regular thing my opener dude first of
all he [ __ ] was chilling with us we
were having a coffee and we were right
before we were going to do the shows or
whatever it was in LA and I'm there with
my Irish friend too and another buddy
Zach Zach donk ovo was there that guy if
you listen to podcast you know that
that's how he laughs and he's got the
highest ass of any non black guy it's
unbelievable his ass is so high he shits
out of his shoulder he's Puerto Rican
and and he had a [ __ ] shirt on that
that would had an old Martin shirt on
that said damn Gina and anyway um my
[ __ ] opener had a bulge we were just
chilling having a good time and he was
like feeling himself you know he he like
ran he had a good [ __ ] jog and then
he took a shower and he felt good he was
just hanging and he was sitting like he
was confident and [ __ ] and I look at his
the back of his knee and he's got a
clump on the back of his knee on his
stupid tight g-star pants that I have to
that he's trying to [ __ ] and be like all
cool in but with an old navy shirt on or
some free swag that he got from a
podcast and and he's like sitting like
he's in charge or some [ __ ] and then I
look on the back and he's got a bulge
and I'm like what the [ __ ] is on the
balm like dude what what do you have on
the back your [ __ ] pants and and he
was like what
and he looked dude he had [ __ ] a sock
in the back of his knee in tight jeans
he looked like such an [ __ ] dude I
should have left it he looked like a
t-rex with it backwards knees he was
[ __ ] tear at with it you ever have
the [ __ ] underwear in the back of
your knees that you put on and you're
like and you have other new one
but your old underwears on because you
[ __ ] either yeah you had sex and you
wiped up the mess with the old [ __ ] or
you [ __ ] wasn't you were a naughty
boy you were naughty boy and you were so
low coming but you've wiped it up with
your [ __ ] with your old underwear and
you put it in your pinion in your pants
and you didn't realize it and it's in
the back of your [ __ ] knee and you
got a messy underwear on the messy sock
on the back your knee and you were in
new underwear but you're like weird that
[ __ ] weird that splooge e [ __ ] go and
you don't know and you're like that's
probably under the bed the dogs got it
and you're walking out and you're I'm
walkin on sunshine but really you got a
[ __ ] splooge EMS in the back your
knee you got a [ __ ] underwear full of
[ __ ] you got coming underwear on the back
of your knee walking around looking like
a t-rex your t-rex and it dude
you got a [ __ ] do you think you're
cool you think you're feeling yourself
dude my opener had a [ __ ] II sock on a
[ __ ] he looked like a t-rex walking
to the coffee shop
oh we were [ __ ] dying dude and then
Zach Tonko Koval couldn't stop laughing
he was God laughs at everything it's
unbelievable oh we were dying anyway
it's on my Instagram if you haven't seen
it if you haven't seen it though
whatever what gives a [ __ ] um but yeah I
got people on my app telling me they've
done it before I've done it with my
underwear before yeah but do you leave
the house do you get to your destination
and do you chill like a confident bro no
you get it before you leave maybe if
you're a chick I understand cuz the
underwears are so sexy and dainty and
small but if you're a dude that shit's
all clumped if you have boxers on bro
what you might as well have to be having
a [ __ ] small you might as well be
having a pumpkin in the back here what
do they call those gourds you might as
well be having a [ __ ] gourd in your
pants
how gross are gourds
dude what do they look like old guys
faces hey gourds get rid all your
[ __ ] awards before
you know hey do you eat those what are
those they can't taste good you ever
have a meal where it's like and and on
the side we have gourds that's why they
named them gourds cuz you would never
eat them anyway look at these [ __ ]
things they're so gross
the last pumpkin asked [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude you know these [ __ ]
gourds you know pumpkins are [ __ ] all
these gourds [ __ ] if I was a gourd
you'd have to be one talented
[ __ ] if you were a gourd you'd
have to like be real good at painting or
singing if you were a gourd you'd have
to be real good at painting or singing
because pumpkins are out there trying to
steal your [ __ ] with your warty ass
body these [ __ ] things some of them
like they have two bodies they have one
body and then it's some gourds have one
body and then it's like a little thin
like segue to another big-ass body it's
like what are you gourd dude gourd suck
the gourds are the worst
some people are gourds you know they're
just like you wanna hang and you're like
you're a gourd what are you a [ __ ]
gourd hey bro you know that chick at the
[ __ ] you know that loud chick that's
like there's like different kinds of
chicks you know there was like the hot
chick that's like the hot chick and
she's an [ __ ] because she's the hot
chick but then there's the hot chick
that had good parents and then she knows
she's the hot chick and so she's like
tries to treat everybody better because
not that she thinks she's better than
but she's like look I know I get stuff
because of my looks so I have to be
careful about that and that's a good
person and it's a hot chick and she's a
good person
it's freaking she be anyway you want to
you could be the nasty hot chick but
could be the nice hot chick right
then there's the girl that's like the
[ __ ] fun friend right that's got the
great personality maybe she's not too
hot his chick whatever but then there's
the girl that's got like the the not
doesn't have the looks but then also
she's like been like so like you know
not paid attention to that she's like
also Loudon
annoying and she's always the girl that
tries to squash you know you trying to
talk to the hot chick right and then the
hot chicks like I really actually have
to leave with my friend because I know
this always happens but she's being
shitty and yeah and that girl also is
shitty and she something look sometimes
has bad breath too that's a gourd
that's a gourd hey girl who does that
the gourd dude it's weird you have arms
and legs because instead of that you
should just have awarded up green body
cuz II gourd I want a girl acts like
that I I want to be like hey how come
you don't have a stem on your head why
don't you have a [ __ ] chode stem on
your head guys are like that too though
you ever get the [ __ ] guy where it's
like oh so cuz some guys are like that
too dude you get the guy that's like
this stuff these are the different guys
too you get the guy that's the [ __ ]
good-looking dude that's like you know
charismatic maybe he's not the smartest
guy but he's a cool dude right good it
like a lot of things and his family's
rich but he's like you know he helps
like society and [ __ ] does something
with like some foundations and then you
get the guy who's just got everything
and then he says stuff like guilt is is
a human is humans are the only one that
feels that feel guilt so it's
unnecessary you do what you have to do
and guilt is a human thing do you think
animals feel guilt No so why would I
have to feel guilt and that guy date
rapes and that guy date rapes and that
guy sucks but he's good-looking so he
tricks a lot of people it tricks a lot
of chicks then you got the guy who's
like the [ __ ] you know stocky like
short guy but like he's like hey what's
going on who's this guy what's up what's
going on with this guy what's is this
guy you know
and then you got another guy who's like
the [ __ ] tall off but like the nice
guy that always is like my best friend's
a chick and then you got but you never
ever ever had sex with her and then you
get the guy that's like the [ __ ]
girls know what I'm talking about - you
get the [ __ ] like pudgy guy that's
like Scott clammy hands but also he
thinks he's God's gift to women to women
women with him God's gift to women I'm
talking too fast babies that's what
happens sometimes you change M's two F's
when you talk too fast but he's thinks
he's God's gift to women but he's not he
just like his may be good at lacrosse a
little bit but also not the best on the
team but he's like the [ __ ] that guy
hey guy got a question for you dude do
you have warts on your midsection
because he gorg dudes chicks don't beat
gourds if you're not that [ __ ]
good-looking you got to work on your
[ __ ] personality man don't be a gourd
don't look bad and not be able to be
served with a [ __ ] salmon huh come on
man at least if you look ugly be like a
[ __ ] you know what looks ugly I mean
all [ __ ] vegetables look ugly but
they taste good sometimes you steamed a
carrot that shit's [ __ ] bonkers
broccoli looks ugly as [ __ ] bro you
steamed it right and put some garlic on
that you put some garlic on broccoli
forget it what are you eating a cookie
dude you put some [ __ ] garlic have
you put a [ __ ] guard
dude if you eat a regular broccoli that
[ __ ] tastes like a cardboard egg do it
if you put garlic and steamed broccoli
and then put a little bit of salt and
pepper on it [ __ ] that [ __ ] no forget it
dude you want to eat some broccoli with
garlic on it
forget it dude this is how I feel when I
eat broccoli with garlic on it there you
go
and I got a bag of broccoli with garlic
on it I got a bag of broccoli with
[ __ ] garlic just holding it walking
down the street you can't stop me dude
if I have [ __ ] garlic and broccoli in
a bag walking down the street with it
[ __ ] you dude go ahead try to [ __ ]
ruin my dad you can't
that's that [ __ ] dude that's good for
you I mean I don't know he's no you know
I don't know what food looks good and is
good but that's where you get chefs
involved chef sir I don't want my food
to look good I don't want it I don't
want my food to look good I don't my
food I just I want it to taste good I
don't need a presentation when you're
watching these chef shows and they're
like I give the presentation the ten do
it guess what if you've got the
presentation to ten the presentation to
me is a zero because it's about making
the food taste good I don't give a [ __ ]
what it looks like oh you put orange on
it I don't care what's the sauce oh man
if one day I'm gonna get Zach here just
to sit and laugh and we're gonna put him
on the other microphone and we're just
gonna that's who should be the [ __ ]
guest that would be hilarious um oh he
goes like that a lot of course he does
by the way he's got a good personality
if he didn't he'd be a [ __ ] gourd I
can't believe he had to [ __ ] sock in
his jeans do it I was on um I'm not
gonna mention this rapper because I
don't want to add him but I was in I was
going to Wichita I was flying to Dallas
first I flew through Dallas to get to
Wichita and mmm boy is that not a
[ __ ] Steve Miller song or not I flew
through Dallas went to Wichita
[ __ ] this dude how come music in the 70s
that came out always sounded like they
were recording so far away from the
[ __ ] microphone any time you listen
to Steve Miller Band I want to be like
hey man get closer to the [ __ ] mic
it's like they're just so echoey and
[ __ ] I hate all that music when people
are talking about hey my favorite band
is Boston or Chicago and he banned him
by a [ __ ] City
yeah hike call yourself the Beatles or
the Foxes or some [ __ ] like that that's
what bands are named um call your
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know Coney Island so I
was at the airport and now I look I'm
not this is not a brag or anything I fly
first class it's it I do it cuz I have
to or business class right I do it
because it's it's not worth it did I
need to be comfortable for my shows I
put I take the money I put it into the
[ __ ] flight you got to be comfortable
Pete Holmes told me that once he's like
dude you got to be comfortable when you
travel that's what you got to make this
and he's right he told me that once on
the way to Montreal and you know you get
first if you can afford it you get the
business because you got it okay I'm not
trying to be but that's what I do also
you know
no no also [ __ ] your also alright so I'm
there and I'm I see a rapper show up and
he's on the flight to Dallas as well now
of course since he's a rapper he's got
90 guys with him all right now dude he's
got his he's got his bodyguard I guess
another guy he's got a few gourds with
him for sure he's got a few gourds with
him for sure as a matter of fact I want
you guys to do got that friend that's
bad looking with a bad personality you
tell him he's a [ __ ] gourd and you
say Chris Thalia sent you tagged him on
his Instagram tagging on a tag Aman is
up on his uh on his Twitter but anyway
so I see this rapper and he's got a few
gourds with him and a bodyguard and he's
got a lot of face tattoos and he's a
young rapper up-and-coming I like some
of his music all right now of course in
real life cuz he talks you know these
rappers allow these rappers like I'm
hard as [ __ ] you don't [ __ ] with me and
if you see them in real life they're
five three I'm telling you these rappers
are five three all these rappers have
short guy complexes that's why they're
talking about ya all this ice [ __ ] you I
got this grill that cost 18k and I
[ __ ] your [ __ ] oh yeah really well
did you put your whole body in her [ __ ]
cuz you five four okay wear your pink
dreads peeking out of her [ __ ] while
you dove in with your feet first so this
guy and also this is how they bust him
not when they're in your girl Oh cuz
they have [ __ ] auto-tune and so so
that's why they don't even they're not
even using auditer auto-tune anymore
they're just that short that that's how
they sound when they rap that's why I
[ __ ] okay and also my mouth didn't
care my mouth um so I see this guy he's
got gourds with him and he's got a
[ __ ] or a girl and he's got oh
they've always got this [ __ ] girl
that's like is she white or an alien
like she's she's so why she's so white
that she's pasty real like oh no maybe
though instead of that he from Saturn
you from Georgia or Saturn she was so
white she was like gray you know what
I'm talking about you know what I'm
talking about
my brother dated a girl once that was so
white she was gray like that gray kind
of tint were you like what was your mom
a white girl and your dad named is
Oregon so he's just like I want you home
by 11:30 no if ands or buts she's like
in him the moms like Zorgon let her hang
it's her prom night it doesn't matter I
know how these humans can get when with
their erections they're going to try and
stick themselves inside of my offspring
so Zorgon and quiet [ __ ] sorry humans
are much more advanced when it comes to
feminism than we are on the planet
travel our [ __ ] you [ __ ] face can I get
out of the basement no this ow
my 11:30 [ __ ] okay dad then she leaves
but anyway so Jesus Christ so so uh so
he's got an alien white girlfriend and a
few gourds with them the [ __ ] and a
bodyguard maybe and they've all got the
worst shoes I'm just gonna
these wrap some of these rappers know
what's up with the shoe wear like
they'll just wear the Jordans are where
the Yeezys the where the cool [ __ ] but
some of these rappers get something I
don't even know that the high tops that
goes so high like to the [ __ ] knee
put a get the food here's a walking
stick dude get out of town all right but
um so I'm what he's got nine guys with
him I'm like dude did I guess he's gonna
fly first and all these other guys are
gonna fly coach or whatever so I get to
the [ __ ] thing and I'll guess if also
they showed up late or not so I'm in
first class and I'm waiting for these
guys and all of them walked past all of
them walked past they're all in coach
this rapper who is he plays bigger
venues than I do and he he he's got you
know the the watch is with the Diamonds
on him I don't know if they're fake but
the chains with diamonds I mean this
guy's got a hundred two hundred three
hundred thousand dollars on his [ __ ]
body and he's not mean it's got to be
fake because he's not flying first why
wouldn't you fly business class if you
had a [ __ ] 40k on your wrist get 38k
on your wrist wrist and get up closer to
the cockpit so so we've walked by man he
walked by he walked on by welcomed by
Bam Bam Bam Bam walk on by dude how
about how music used to be anyway um so
we [ __ ] I mean dude how about music
used to be you know we uh live in a
yellow submarine you know and people are
like music isn't that good nowadays oh
yeah
sup with that Yellow Submarine song so
anyway um so anyway he walked on by man
and he [ __ ] and he didn't do it he
played was in coach with his [ __ ] 18
gourds just chillin and then a [ __ ]
but less like what the [ __ ] these
rappers are all lying
if this guy's learning the raw lying
that's crazy dude
like it's it's embarrassing if you're
like yo I'm a rapper I get money I got
money I [ __ ] your [ __ ] and it's
excuse me I need to get my bag up there
excuse me can I get peanuts do we get
meals no only in the only in the
business class okay can I get peanuts
and pretzels please we ran out kay I'll
just sit so I racked I'll just sit so I
wrecked it's unbelievable just weird
dude but yeah man had hadn't had not had
had none of that [ __ ] I also didn't
have the ice on are they renting it or
they just I don't understand man I don't
understand it that lifestyles so [ __ ]
crazy
anyway mm-hmm quip when you walk down
the toothbrush aisle at the store it
doesn't take longer realize there are
lots of options I mean give me a
headache why don't you write many of
them are gimmicks the truth is you
really just need something that guides
the simple habits most of us get wrong
when brushing our teeth and that's why
you get cavities and you get plaque
buildup but quip knows that first
artists quip is an electric toothbrush
that's a fraction of the cost of bulkier
brushes and it's got the right amount of
vibrations to help clean your teeth it
also helps you it'll pulse like it's
time to switch to your other side so you
know that you get the dentist
recommended allotted time for each side
and each way you're brushing your teeth
and they're backed by a network of over
20,000 dentists and hygienists and
hundreds of thousands of happy brushers
used clip every day I do including me I
take it on the road with me and my teeth
are really
I drink coffee all the time but my teeth
well are they white why are they so
white
why would I smile it goes ding thanks to
quip clip starts at just $25 and if you
go to get clip comm / Congrats right now
you'll get your first refill pack free
with a quip electric toothbrush that's
your first refill pack free at get quip
comm / Congrats spelled GE tqu IP comm /
Congrats me on DS now I love me on these
you've heard me talk about them a
million times I'm wearing them now why
am I so obsessed with them it's as
simple as this when I wake up in the
morning all groggy I actually get
excited to go to my underwear drawer and
pick out which me undies I want to wear
for the day because the styles are
awesome I can go plain gray I can go
plain I can get purple I can go nice
with some cool like Aztec e'en symbols
on them they got one I got colorful ones
I got ones with rainbows on them I mean
I got ones with I they got all sorts I
got army camouflage
it's very cool they got I'm wearing it's
like my own secret I'm wearing my crazy
fun print and nobody else knows and I
walk around like this because nobody
knows what I got around my privates I
love them they use micromotor fabric
which is a full three times softer than
regular cotton I couldn't believe how
soft these things were honestly when I
put them on you want the fabric down
there trust me 100% satisfaction
guarantee you're going to love these
undies but if you're not into it just
send them back for a full refund there
is a me and he's just lost launched a
brand new membership you can level up
your top drawer with new undies each
month so get your first 50% off your
first pair get your 15 percent off your
first pair free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
com / Congrats that's me undies dot-com
/ Congrats can't go wrong blue apron I
love blue apron I would eat it every
meal if I could I'm on the road a lot at
a you know all the time when I'm home
blue apron delivers farm-fresh
ingredients and step-by-step recipes to
your door it's easy
I like blue apron because it I've never
I've never had a bad meal and I VI must
have eaten 40 of them so far but they're
really great they also opened my eyes to
stuff I didn't
no I would like that I've never had I'm
not really a pork guy but when blue
apron shows up with some pork with some
pork meals I eat it
I love it and now guess what I'm a pork
guy thanks blue apron quick and easy
recipes perfectly portioned ingredients
delivered right next right right to your
door it's cool you got like the carbs
you got the protein you got all the
stuff you need the joy of summer is
experienced with the favorite grilling
recipe seasonally inspired ingredients
mouth-watering grilling options for the
summer chicken with barbecue sauce and
juicy cheeseburgers with spicy slaw oh
come on do it I'm angry now so check out
this week's menu and get your first
three meals free at blue apron calm /
Congrats that's blue apron dot-com /
congrats to get your first three meals
free blue apron a better way to cook so
anyway we do in it hey hey me
so yeah rappers fly coach man I don't
know if you know that but big rappers
with millions of followers fly coach I
was watching that movie district 9 you
ever watch that movie with district 9
what is that up there picture no I I
I saw district 9 but when it came out
but I I always think about this about
people like it's impossible for us to be
honest with someone because we are never
honest with ourselves or it's we're not
never but it's so hard to be honest with
ourselves for int and this is what made
me think about it all over again I was
watching the movie district 9 and in the
movie district 9 I'm not gonna ruin for
you but in the beginning so the movie is
about these aliens come down to earth in
their in South America and be what
alright I'll have a guy sorry they're in
South Africa and one higher correcta me
in a good way so they're in South Africa
and they they land there or there
they've been there already and they have
like this area that is like the
quote/unquote ghetto where they stay and
hang out and the South Africans are like
you know what we need to move them so
they get the government in South Africa
to move them into these basically camps
which is a lot like what you see now
going on with Trump's wall and [ __ ] like
that so what happens is they get one of
the guys in one of these government
positions that is like you're gonna be
the guy that leads and goes into these
houses and basically it's a peon job
it's dangerous but he's like yeah I'll
do it because it's like awesome you guys
need me he's like one of these like
little you know guys that's a beta that
and ends up in this position where he's
like yeah cool everyone likes me I'll do
it so he goes and does it and when he
does it he's there and he's like he's
looking for paraphernalia is looking for
weapons he's looking for drugs and he
finds this one thing we're and you know
he's such a goof boys kind of happy they
just look at this position and so he's
like okay so we found this one thing I
don't know what it is and this is what
the movies about is in the beginning so
I'm not ruining it but this canister he
it spray it it it pops and it sprays and
it goes into his face and he starts
coughing and he's like oh I don't know
what it is but it's not it he's like
it's not a weapon but it's it's
definitely dangerous so or way he's like
it's not a weapon but it's dangerous so
I'm taking it in but it can be dangerous
but it's and it's definitely not a
weapon and then he gets sprayed and he's
like don't worry it's not a weapon it's
not a weapon
and he's lying to us but he thinks he's
telling the truth he's just lying to
himself he's saying it out loud because
he wants it to not be true so he's lying
to himself so him telling us that is not
necessarily a lie
he thinks it's the truth but he's but he
probably wouldn't know it if he really
sat down and thought oh no I'm actually
scared at his weapon I'm saying it's
dangerous but it's not a weapon which
makes no sense of it's dangerous it is a
weapon so that is what we do all day
long we do a version of that all day
long we do it all day long we do it
consciously when somebody says are you
hungry I'm not is it nom not hungry we
don't need to eat but you're hungry and
then we do it stuff like where it's like
dude I'm happy with my body like this
[ __ ] that I don't want to be one of
those guys that doesn't eat carbs and
doesn't enjoy life when really you want
the good body or whatever the [ __ ] right
but a lot of those people are like that
so it's hard to not be a liar as my
point we're all [ __ ] lying all day
long we're all lying to ourselves all
day long because we say [ __ ] like that
man I mean granted there's like a
percentage of people that do it a little
a you know less of a percentage than
most of the people but dude so that
movie made me think about that because
the acting was so good and the guy was
so good and it just felt like it was
funny I was like ah that's that thing I
think about sometimes you know like
we're all [ __ ] lying always in that
movie it hey dude
arts good babies I I know I blast art a
lot but that's what [ __ ] that's what
I'm saying
art art made me [ __ ] realize
something all over again it's important
art changed my life in that one moment
art changed my life I'm ordering food on
your [ __ ] dude ordered food
but yeah movies teach lessons is what
I'm trying to say my words and what
pills I use them across my opponents you
ever hear that Eminem song my worn some
weapons I use them across my opponents
my words and weapons Chris my opponents
and bonus the bonus I make the bonus the
bonus the bonus Jonas and my bonus and
Chili's and bonus long as the donuts my
don't dunk down it's a bomb isn't on
them
I get you bonus on the PO mr. Jonas a
bump bonus man oh wait was it gonna go
up these ones and weapons I never show
no emotion even though I'm angry right
now what I mean when I don't show
emotions is the don't cry even though
one got songs about crap basically
hypocrite in just like even though I'm
crying handle myself like gonna gag
doesn't disagree
millena myself like I'm not even know
what seeing nothing I'm crying even
awesome you know seeing the crying man
like the gang dissing Eminem always
sound like he's under a truck get this
trunk up off me I got bad luck to the
drunken district I mean being a lot what
the [ __ ] is the trunk armies being like
get the truck off me about Chuck that's
Chuck
Pazhani with the funk the gun some bad
luck my wards are weapons but they don't
help me now
well my warns and weapons but they don't
get this trunk on me before up trunk I'm
funk the venison lat it's a bad luck I'm
gonna be crying but I never shown almost
even Norman I like the game district I
love what I'm doing all this and I'm
sweating my balls off and then I look
over one fire and I ever get rid of it
and they're literally just like googling
porn or whatever not laughing
it's so awesome dude just googling
interracial porn [ __ ] man I love it dude
[ __ ] yeah look Siri literally I pick up
my phone in Siri says I don't know how
to respond to that and it that's what it
says I never I didn't hit her button
she's just like what the [ __ ] are you
doing doing what are you doing
um yeah dude this is a fun funky fun the
funky episode dude we're having a good
time dude
I just want to I'm down for a silly
goose time and that's it man that's it
and guess and there's two things I don't
give a [ __ ] about this week man a new
segment called two things I don't give a
[ __ ] about I don't give a [ __ ] if
pineapple belongs on pizza or not stop
talking about it either get Hawaiian
pizza or don't why do people get
consumed with things that aren't things
he born piece of [ __ ] you gourd turn
around let me grab your stem and push it
closer to my [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] you doggy
style gourd get out of here you're
boring
hey pineapple a so what's the deal you
like pineapple on Petes are not you born
excuse me let me catch some Z's while
you ask that question
hey is your favorite letters
cuz here's a pocket full of them I got a
pocketful of Z's and I'm about to take a
nap can you're thinking about pineapple
dude here's another thing I don't give a
flying rat [ __ ] about is die if die hard
is a Christmas movie or not it doesn't
matter
you boring guy at a party take out good
take out a guitar who gives a [ __ ] if
diehard is a Christmas movie or not you
know why it's a movie you can watch
watch it at Christmas if you wanna or
watch it in June cuz if you're asking me
that question I've got another pocket
full of Z's for ya who gives a [ __ ] you
uninteresting guard how interesting that
are you a Gorn cuz the Lord how
interesting is it that Gord rhymes to
the board and you look going cuz I'm
bored I'm on the world tour but I can't
get doesn't mannequins don't born born
and I got my pockets fanuc aziz these
are my fan where song ever we're a song
of all time yeah do it I don't care
about both of those things man so stop
ask it's not making cervezas die hard a
Christmas movie or not doesn't matter
dub man
dub man you know what also is for the
birds dude sixty-nining yo if something
feels good on my [ __ ] I don't want
anything in my mouth dude what the [ __ ]
dude I used to know I know this guy who
he said dude he's said he's 69 all the
time and I was like really why and he
was like dude I don't know sometimes I
just fall into it and we were roasting
him so hard in the [ __ ] at the 101
diner well dude I was
laughing we were pretending he was
getting a blow job and he was like oh no
no no no and the girl was turning around
he was like no no no and he couldn't
stop like he would try so I don't know I
did it
he told us he did it in the bathtub once
and we were dude we were pissing and
[ __ ] and crying so hard dude we were
laughing so hard we're like in a bathtub
like how do you even turn around in the
bathtub we get it on a bed you could
[ __ ] spin around but in a bathtub
dude if it feels good on my privates
guess what I'm not doing
munching forget that dude also dude you
know what that's that's where the phrase
I can't be bothered came out oh I'm
about to [ __ ] bust mine I'm about to
[ __ ] who's that politician that's
name booster money what's his name how
was that guy's name every time I read
that guy's name I think bless my nutty
childish but anyway dude always a lawyer
I think actually anyway whatever [ __ ]
it doesn't matter dude I can't be
bothered dude and neither can the chick
man if it feels good on her [ __ ] face
hugger then dude why are you gonna if
you're making her face hugger feel good
then why are you concentrated on dude
that so [ __ ] frat guy to be like yeah
I'm making a [ __ ] I'm making a feel
good but let me see if I could weasel my
[ __ ] in work you do it yeah but let me
see I'll do it yeah I'm gonna make a [ __ ]
so hot
balloons if I could weighs on my [ __ ] in
her mouth you see I gotta get mine too
though yeah I mean they say just about
the making of it I mean look I lay it
down in the bedroom when it comes to
laying flat with a girl
I'm putting work I'm just saying if we
could spin around kill two birds with
one stone I
can't be bothered with sixty-nining dude
I can't be bothered we you know I mean
it's like come on whatever anyway dude
it's the first time I ever called a
vagina [ __ ] face hugger that's for
sure hey there's a first for everything
isn't there there's a first time how
about when people say that hey there's a
first time for everything really mm-hmm
not everything you guys heard about this
farmers dog dog food companies claim to
use all natural ingredients but what
kind of beef or carrots can sit on a
shelf for years it's a good question
we can't eat highly processed food every
meal and be healthy and neither can your
dog quite frankly the healthiest
healthiest food for your dog is real
fresh unprocessed food introducing the
farmers dog the company helping dogs
live longer and healthier lives with
fresh ready to serve meals delivered
directly to your door clever marketing
has convinced pet owners to feed
unhealthy and highly processed kibble
but the farmers dog is different
complete a short questionnaire and a vet
developed meal plan is created just for
your dog food arrives at your door in
pre-portion packs ready to open and pour
it's easy and looks and smells like real
food because it is real food food
matters all right like we're at the age
where we know that now studies show that
even adding fresh food to your dog's
diet can reduce cancer risks by 90% so
if you don't want your dog to get cancer
get farmers dog start feeding your dog
better today get 50% off your two-week
trial of fresh healthy food at farmers
at the farmer's dog calm slash Congrats
plus you get free shipping just go to
the farmers dog com / congrats to get
your 50% off your first two weeks that's
the farmers dog calm / Congrats square
cash the app the cash app you know cash
app because we talk about it all the
time they're huge sponsors of our shows
and they're that way for a reason
because I like it
I use it all the time it's a simplest
way to instantly send money to friends
it's also the number one app in finance
the cash card is a free customizable
debit card that you can use at stores or
ATMs it's linked to your cash app
balance as if it were a checking account
it even lets you direct deposit your
paycheck if you're looking for an
alternative to traditional banking
banking you're not alone millions of
Americans have already started using the
cash card cash app is also the most
convenient and inexpensive way to buy
sell and withdraw bitcoin and bitcoin is
kind of the thing right now so if you
don't think I'm drunk there's never been
a rewards program like boosts get
instant discounts every single time you
swipe your cash card at coffee shops
Chipotle Shake Shack and beyond just tap
a boost in the app and pay with your
cash card and of course when you
download the cash app and enter reward
code Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund download the cash app for free on
the cat on the App Store or Google Play
market cruise bustamante that's his name
cruz bust my nutty yeah anyway um I
don't know I was thinking a lot when I
was a kid about me when I was a kid cuz
I was thinking about like kids and if I
wasn't gonna have him and stuff but dude
I want to go on record and I know I know
some high school kids probably listen to
this and I want to be a bad influence
but I [ __ ] hated school dude the
second I got it I went to one year NYU
and I [ __ ] bounced I didn't go a year
I dropped I like stopped going to class
oh I bounced the [ __ ] out while I'm
sweating [ __ ] I bounced the [ __ ] out um
I was such a [ __ ] weird out dude I
was so scared too as a kid I thought
everyone was gonna murder me and aliens
were gonna come down and [ __ ] Birds
we're gonna add up abduct me I remember
one time I think I told the
[ __ ] Isis but my dad was like what are
you scared of just go to bed and I was
in my bed and I said everything Birds
yeah I did tell that I did I did right
but uh yeah I I was scared I would have
to go to school and I was so scared dude
cuz I was like I don't trust these
[ __ ] teachers dude I was like I
was like here we go here comes the
mention I was like Tupac in these
[ __ ] I was like I'm I don't
trust these I don't trust these
[ __ ] just some teacher that has
a job that can abduct me get out of here
dude
so I um the first time I went to school
I I'm I I made my dad wait I was like
that you gotta wait outside the hallways
like I can't wait and he pretend he did
and then the second and then the second
I got free I got a lookout and he wasn't
there dude he went back home and I was
so up so I think I told this story on
the podcast but I went I went home and I
was like my mom was like how was school
and I was like ha how was it well I
don't know if you know this but dad's a
liar it's probably Jaden Anya it's
probably got another family why well
because I asked him to stay outside of
the classroom in the hallway of
Northeast School in Montclair New Jersey
and he said he would and instead he went
to work so you might want to look around
for that other family cuz dad's a liar
anyway I'll be going playing with my
Hemans and transformers let me know what
you find out there's no Google or
Internet so there's no possible way you
can find out if he's cheating so good
luck but go ahead
and then the other one was when I had to
go to the next year I was like dude I
don't want to have I just figured out
how to be with this teacher and I trust
her and then I had to go to school
another year and there's a new [ __ ]
lady that's gonna I'm gonna have to I
don't trust these I don't trust these
holes dude
I was five not trust in these hoes okay
you think you're [ __ ] or you think
you're cool rapper cuz you're you're 18
25 30 not trust in these hoes bro I
wasn't trust in these hoes before I was
walking I used to be afraid of the
[ __ ] Twizzlers commercial because
they had random female lips on him
eating Twizzlers do that [ __ ] freaked me
the [ __ ] out my mom would be like what
what are you so scared of and I'd be
like mouths I was so scared of lips when
I was a kid right because that's where
that's when [ __ ] these hoes start
trifling man from the lips man they tell
you these lies these [ __ ] 1984
Twizzlers commercials bro these
Twizzlers commercials in 1984 with the
lips bro they used to scare the [ __ ]
outta me man eating Twizzlers saying
they taste like strawberries
bro we don't know what they taste like
you know why cuz these hoes are trifling
man they make your mouth happy alright
anyway I was uh you know guess what all
women had lips dude
Houck I trust these hos when these
Twizzlers commercials worked crazy and
scary as [ __ ] so I'd have to go to
school with a [ __ ] Anna knew I just
figured out my old school I gotta come
to a new [ __ ] class with a new
teacher with a new set of lips on her
get out of here dude so I [ __ ] went
and I was like you know what I know I
can't trust not only can I not trust
these hoes but I can't trust my dad
either
my own [ __ ] he made me I can't trust
his [ __ ] because he's gonna
choose work over me so I went to school
and I was like yeah let me just sit
through this intro I can't
wait till the class has to get up and go
get some supplies cuz this second we
gotta go get some supplies guess what
I'm doing I'm [ __ ] yo the movie Fast
and Furious is about me so I'd like ok
class that's what we're doing today go
everyone get up and get your [ __ ]
cardboard and scissors or whatever the
[ __ ] get your cardboard and dull
scissors that you couldn't kill a
[ __ ] fly in a lazy caterpillar with
so I did dude I walked over near the
door like somebody with a secret and I
had one I was gonna dip the [ __ ] out
dude and I waited near that door
nonchalantly like a [ __ ]
chillin while everyone and I remember
looking at the teacher and I thought
this second she turns around I'm dipping
out and I remember thinking as a 5 year
old or 6 year old or wherever old I was
5 6
I got a do it like nothing's wrong I
gotta do it like I'm not doing it this
is where I was just like I gotta pretend
like I'm just you know I can just walk
well [ __ ] it
she doesn't know maybe I'm going to look
at something outside so I remember I was
looking at her and I remember I set it
up to where I was gonna just take a step
backwards I wasn't even gonna turn
around cuz that was gonna it was gonna
that was gonna take more time than just
backing up so I was like that Homer
Simpson Jeff where he goes into the
bushes you know and I [ __ ] in and I just
backed the [ __ ] up I just backed up dude
I just straight up was looking at this
chick and I backed up like a homosexual
looking for a [ __ ] and I [ __ ] backed
up and I and as soon as I backed up and
was at a plain view when she turned
around I [ __ ] I ran so fast to the I
was in the hallway all the schools were
inside and the East Coast because of
weather and Armageddon and I ran out I
hit that [ __ ] laude [ __ ] door long
you know that big ass rod that is
connected to that red door Bob boom ran
out and I was due
I was free I was free and I knew the way
home it was three blocks away we only
lived three blocks away on West View
Road and I [ __ ] ran and I went I hit
that I hit as soon as I got onto that
parking lot guess what I saw dude guess
what I saw the worst thing you could
possibly [ __ ] say one teacher I saw
one teacher I actually don't even think
she was a teacher I think she was there
for like some sort of conference thing
whatever what you know what she had onto
a brown blazer with a brown skirt and a
[ __ ] frilly thing that was like I'm a
woman but also respect me because this
is the 80s and she guess what guess if
she had short hair or not you already
know the answer she did and I was I
literally thought like this I I
literally thought it was all quick in my
head but I literally thought this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] chick thinks she
can stop me
I already got through the hard part I
snuck out
she ain't catching me and I saw her and
it was like a [ __ ] Matador I was like
oh [ __ ] and I stopped in my tracks she
looked at me dude she this woman in this
[ __ ] skirt suit straight up got into
a [ __ ] Kiba dachi stance she
straight-up lowered her Center for
center of gravity
looked at me and like a lineman put her
[ __ ] hands out and I was like oh
she's gonna try and catch me and I was
like here we go [ __ ] make her
break dude and I swear to god dude this
musics for the
and I and I [ __ ] dude I pivoted and I
[ __ ] started running running as fast
as my six-year-old legs could [ __ ]
take and I didn't I wasn't a sports guy
but I did a Juke move
I did a Juke move on this girl with her
skirt suit and I [ __ ] faked laughs I
remember I faked left and I went right
dude and she was what we didn't forget
about what we forget about is how much
bigger adults are than six-year-olds and
all she had to do was grab me and she
grabbed me lifted me off the ground with
my little six-year-old feet kicking I'm
like nah and she brought me back to
class and you know what the craziest
thing about the rest of the [ __ ]
story is I don't remember beyond that I
remember I tried to Juke I uh Hillary
Clinton lookin ass [ __ ] and I
have and eye moves remember being so mad
at that chick for being there because
she wasn't a teacher she was just there
for some conference I remember and I was
like she's not even a [ __ ] teacher
and she caught me dude why is she doing
that she doesn't even work for the
school you know why is she trying to
catch kids dude I should have said she
touched me man she brought me right back
dude and my mom was like you tried to I
got home and I was like she was like you
tried to run away I was like yeah
[ __ ] I did dub i whole world's upside
down dad's a liar and I [ __ ] I tried
to run home I couldn't get past it but
dude I'm a man and I couldn't get past a
lady you think I don't know we're
[ __ ] West we wrote is dude yeah I
caught I caught the [ __ ] drives I get
it I'm a kid but I know dude I knew how
to get to West View Road man it was
right next to Northeast you used to
catch girls dude I used to do that when
I was in school I used to catch girls
that used to be a thing I remember me
and [ __ ] Cory bovver and he had one
weird little ping
he did Cory Bober had a little deformity
just one little pinky that was weird
but other than that he was just regular
person DUP and and one that bad he had
one pinky and he used to tell people
that he got it because the [ __ ] car a
car his mom slammed the door in the cart
and his and his pinky got [ __ ] up I
think all the kids knew that he was born
with it but he still would lie about it
because why wouldn't he I would too dude
that guy had cool 80s hair I remember
Cory Bolger and and and he used to tell
us that Jimmy Hoffa was buried in his
basement for real and I told my dad
about it my dad laughed so hard he cried
he said dude youth he's he's trying to
tell you Jimmy Hoffa's buried in his
basement and I was like we was like well
they never found him
he's like Jimmy Jude Cory Bober thought
Jimmy Hoffa was buried in his [ __ ]
basement in New Jersey because of some
cat paw prints that were embedded in the
cement and he was like Jimmy Hoffa had
cats and the owner knew Jimmy Hoffa the
last owner knew Jimmy Hoffa and he was
in the [ __ ] mafia so you do the math
and I was like this math is done my
friend I'm gonna tell my dad about this
and if my dad can do that math Jimmy
Hoffa is in your basement and we're
gonna come down and we're gonna look at
it and my dad left so [ __ ] hard dude
he laughed so hard that he was crying
and he said next time and he was like no
Jimmy Hoffa was not buried in your
friend [ __ ] quarry bober's basement
he was like next time you see Jay he was
like next time you leave school go tell
Cory Bober does what you got to say to
him half a nice day and my dad was laugh
and rolling around on the ground
actually on the couch and then he went
on the ground and started rolling around
do it up so funny have a nice day
half a nice day
so no I don't know if they found Jimmy
Hoffa's since or not but that's not
where Jimmy Hoffa was in Cory Booker's
basement and he also lied about his
pinkie being slammed in a [ __ ] car
door because his mom was at the grocery
store and needed to get there very
quickly because that's what he said
but anyway Cory Bober and I used to
[ __ ] catch chicks we catch girls
maybe running around
girls like rosemary and Ronnie would be
running around and we would catch him
once we kept we you know I mean it's not
like we would put him anywhere but we be
like gotcha and then we'd go get another
one and then they just run around and go
on the [ __ ] monkey bars or some [ __ ]
or whatever terrible [ __ ] playground
murderous devices they had and oh man
who was it Doug that [ __ ] smashed his
balls on the monkey bars god damn that
was the first real pain I saw as a kid
he was standing on the monkey bars where
you try to climb up and he goes and he
felt that his balls hit the [ __ ]
thing and he just goes oh this face got
so red and just ran into the [ __ ]
classroom [ __ ] man I think his name is
Doug Wow what the [ __ ] are these kids
doing now you know Wow
I think Ronnie dm2 me recently I I
missed I [ __ ] I don't know if I
accepted it or not she's probably
kicking around Watchung Plaza going to
Tony's getting some [ __ ] Sour Patch
Kids
or some warheads it's what we used to do
back then when we didn't even know what
Asians were man we didn't even know what
Asians were dude and now they got
another taking over with which rich
crazy Asians dude god bless all right
well we're done we had a great time
tonight today whenever you're listening
to this remember to download the Chris
D'Elia app go to the wherever apps are
made download it blue apron blue apron
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals free a blue apron calm
/ congrats and also download the cash
app for free on the kit on the App Store
or Google Play market and two rewards
code Congrats get $5 and give five
dollars - times up we really truly
appreciate you guys listening and
spreading the word of this cult thank
you
maybe spread it to somebody this week
tell somebody about the podcast let them
know cuz our numbers need to be going up
because if we're not pushing forward
we're dying dude it's like a business
new merch available we got there was
those Grand Slam teas man get it and
slam your [ __ ] enemies and slam
your your loved ones they say the LEAs
on them and they're of a reminiscent
food chain that you might say follow the
leader buy tickets at Chris D'Elia com
follow the leader buy tickets at Chris
D'Elia calm we added a new show in
Boston let's get it guys Reno Las Vegas
is actually already sold out which is
awesome because Vegas is hard to sell
out beforehand because it's a very late
crowd so congratulations to me thank you
very much me Ottawa Ontario London
Ontario Buffalo New York Burlington
Philadelphia Vancouver Miami West Palm
Beach Jacksonville Atlanta a bunch of
other cities go look go look and
subscribe to the YouTube channel videos
come out every Tuesday or Wednesday even
though in the last week we didn't pipe
on get rid up but we're gonna have it up
early this week so watch my [ __ ] on
Netflix too and stream alone together on
network at a Netflix special coming
opportunities all right you guys
remember a nice day
[Music]